Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
J'ai été violée.
Je vous rassure,
je ne vais pas vous raconter,
je ne vais pas vous décrire combien
c’était horrible, violent, traumatisant.
Je ne veux pas vous mettre mal à l’aise,
mais peut-être l’êtes-vous déjà un peu
à l’idée de m’entendre parler de ce sujet.
Je ne peux pas vous en vouloir,
mais je vais en parler quand même.
Du viol ?
Pas vraiment,
mais précisément de ce malaise
que l’on ressent lorsqu’on
nous parle de viol.
Ce malaise, on pourrait l'appeler tabou.
Et si je veux en parler,
c’est parce qu’il a
des conséquences graves.
Parce que c’est tabou,
très peu de victimes portent plainte.
Seulement 10%.
Faisant du viol un crime largement impuni.
Parce que c’est tabou,
certaines victimes n’en parlent
à personne,
pas même à leurs proches.
Parce que c’est tabou, elles ressentent
de la honte, de la culpabilité,
et ce poids terrible les freinera
dans leur reconstruction
après ce grave traumatisme.
Et parce que c’est tabou
lorsqu’elles essaieront d’en parler,
elles feront souvent face à des réactions
maladroites
ou même délétères
qui les dissuaderont
d’en parler à nouveau.
On met en doute leur parole :
« Oh ! t’es sûre ?!
T’exagères pas un peu là ? »
« Ah non, je le connais,
jamais il ferait ça. »
ou encore
« Bah, il y avait de l’alcool, tu sais,
on ne sait pas vraiment
ce qui s’est passé. »
On aimerait se dire que le viol,
ça n’existe pas.
Pour ça,
on hésite même à prononcer son nom :
« J’ai été violée.
- Ah bon ? Tu as subi
un rapport sexuel non consenti ? »
Parfois, on minimise :
« Ouais, ça a dérapé, quoi.
C’est pas si grave, tu t’en remettras.
Allez ! Faut passer
à autre chose maintenant. »
Pourtant, le viol
a de graves conséquences qui sont
méconnues et mal prises en charge,
des conséquences
qui peuvent durer des années,
voire toute la vie.
Le stress post-traumatique,
comme pour une victime de guerre,
cause reviviscences, flash-back,
cauchemars, sensation de danger permanent.
Le viol génère aussi
des crises d’angoisse, de la dépression,
parfois des addictions,
des troubles du comportement alimentaire,
de l’agressivité.
Et puis, il y a les troubles physiques.
Fatigue, douleurs chroniques,
troubles gynécologiques,
troubles digestifs,
troubles neurologiques.
La liste est immense.
Si bien que l’espérance de vie
des personnes violées est diminuée.
Et il y a quatre fois plus de risques
de suicide chez les femmes violées.
Alors, revenons à nos réactions.
Parfois, on ne sait tellement pas
quoi dire qu’on change carrément de sujet,
on coupe court à la conversation :
« Ah OK.
Bon bah, je dois y aller.
Et puis, on en reparle
ou pas. »
Ou alors, on ramène les choses à soi :
« Ah, depuis que tu m’as raconté ça,
je suis pas bien, j’en dors plus. »
ou alors à quelqu’un d’autre :
« Ah ouais, c’est arrivé aussi
à ma cousine.
Et puis, elle, quand ça lui est arrivé,
eh ben... »
Et on oublie totalement la personne
qui tentait de nous parler d'elle.
On fait parfois preuve
d’une curiosité mal placée :
« Mais il t’a fait quoi exactement ? »
« Et je comprends pas,
c’est lui qui t’a déshabillée ou... ? »
« Et il avait une arme ? »
Ces questions sont douloureuses
parce qu’elles obligent
la victime à revivre le viol.
D’autre part, elles illustrent bien
les mythes qu’on a autour du viol
commis par un étranger,
les yeux injectés de sang,
armé d’un couteau
dans un parking souterrain.
Pourtant, dans 90% des cas,
l’agresseur est connu de la victime
et les viols n’ont pas si souvent lieu
dans les parkings souterrains.
Enfin, on peut insinuer
que la victime aurait pu faire autrement :
« Mais pourquoi t’es pas partie ? »,
« Mais pourquoi t’as pas crié ? »,
« Mais tu pouvais pas t’enfuir ? »,
« Mais t’avais pas vu que ce mec-là,
il était bizarre ? »,
« Mais pourquoi t’es allée chez un mec
que tu connaissais pas, d’ailleurs ? »
Le viol,
c’est bien le seul crime pour lequel
on suspecte systématiquement la victime.
On se demande si elle avait eu
une attitude provocante,
comment elle était habillée.
On atténue la responsabilité du violeur.
Parfois sans faire exprès,
sans s’en rendre compte.
J’ai souvent entendu :
« A moi, ça m’arriverait pas. »
L’idée que ça puisse arriver
à n’importe qui fait tellement peur,
qu’on préfère se dire
que ça n’arrive qu’aux autres,
que la victime n’a pas dû faire
ce qu’il fallait,
qu’elle doit y être
pour quelque chose.
Mais le viol,
ça peut arriver à tout le monde.
Ça peut arriver à vos enfants,
à votre meilleure amie.
C’est peut-être arrivé à votre mère
ou à votre petite amie
et vous ne le savez pas
parce que c’est tabou.
Ça arrive aux femmes, aux hommes,
aux enfants.
Et ce n'est jamais de leur faute.
Il est tellement difficile
de trouver les mots
que le silence est bien souvent
la solution adoptée.
On n’en parle pas, on évite le sujet
et même quand on veut bien faire,
bien réagir avec empathie, sans jugement,
on ne sait pas comment faire.
On rougit, on regarde ailleurs.
On présuppose que la victime
ne souhaite pas en parler.
Et ça nous arrange.
Le viol est un tabou tellement puissant
que lorsqu’on est victime,
très rapidement,
on se met à préserver les autres
de son vécu
pour ne pas mettre mal à l’aise,
pour ne pas déranger,
pour ne pas pourrir l’ambiance.
D’ailleurs, j’ai commencé la conférence
en disant « Je vous rassure. »
J’ai quand même eu besoin
de vous rassurer
sur le fait que je n’allais pas
gâcher la soirée.
Comme tous les tabous,
le viol fait peur.
Et comme tous les traumatismes graves,
c’est un sujet difficile.
Mais le tabou autour du viol
a quelque chose de spécifique
car on le rattache systématiquement
à la sphère du privé,
de l’intime, de la sexualité.
Vous savez, ces choses
dont on ne parle pas.
Alors parlons-en justement.
Le viol est-il intime ?
Je vous ai dit que j'ai été violée.
Est-ce que pour autant,
je vous ai dévoilé mon intimité ?
Est-ce que je vous ai parlé
de ma sexualité ?
« Non, mais on se dit que, forcément,
ça doit avoir un impact
sur ta vie sexuelle, donc euh... »
Peut-être.
Peut-être pas.
Ce genre de lien qu’on fait
un peu rapidement
sans vraiment prendre le temps
de s’interroger,
c’est un raccourci.
Imaginez le nombre de choses qui peuvent
avoir un impact sur la vie sexuelle.
La fatigue,
les médicaments,
un accident de voiture, avoir mal au dos
et des centaines d’autres.
Est-ce qu’on dit à quelqu’un
qui a une lombalgie chronique :
« Ben en fait, j’ose pas t’en parler
parce que je me dis
que ça doit perturber
ta vie sexuelle et du coup,
c’est intime » ?
Le viol n’est pas un type de sexualité,
il ne concerne pas du tout la sexualité,
d’ailleurs,
il est à mettre du côté
de la violence.
C'est un crime violent.
Alors très curieusement,
souvent lorsque j’explique ça,
on me répond :
« Oui t’as raison
mais c’est quand même intime. »
Ne serions-nous pas
en train de nous cacher
derrière cette notion d’intimité
pour éviter le sujet ?
Car on ne s’occupe pas
de l’intimité des gens,
alors que les faits de société
dont fait partie le viol
concernent tout le monde.
Tout le monde parce qu’il est le symptôme
d’une société qui dysfonctionne
avec de la violence entre les personnes,
avec des systèmes oppressifs
de domination.
Mais tout le monde aussi
parce que vous connaissez
tous et toutes des victimes de viol.
En France, une femme sur six
déclare avoir vécu un viol
ou une tentative de viol
au cours de sa vie
et un homme sur vingt.
Faites le calcul autour de vous.
Vous êtes tous
des interlocuteurs potentiels.
Alors, comment casser ce tabou ?
Ce n’est pas tant
de la responsabilité des victimes.
C’est bien beau de dire :
« Les victimes doivent parler »
mais les victimes ne peuvent parler
que si elles sont écoutées.
La réaction qu’on peut avoir facilement,
c’est de dire :
« Mais c’est à la justice
que tu dois aller raconter ça. »
Alors oui, en théorie,
c’est le rôle de la justice.
Entendre la parole des victimes,
agir en conséquence.
Mais combien de viols
sont-ils réellement condamnés
en tant que tels ?
1%
Dans mon cas, quatre ans de procédure,
un non-lieu.
Comme si ça n'avait pas eu lieu.
Alors, qui peut écouter
si la justice ne le fait pas ?
Nous tous.
Un ami, un collègue, un père,
une mère, un frère, une cousine.
Nous sommes tous cela.
Comment faire ?
Eh bien, ce n’est pas si compliqué.
Au minimum, on doit entendre
et reconnaître la réalité
et la gravité
de ce que la personne a vécu.
On peut dire qu’on la croit,
que ça a dû être très difficile
pour elle, terrible.
Bref, on fait preuve d’empathie.
On peut reconnaître qu’en parler est
une démarche difficile et l’encourager :
« Tu as beaucoup de courage
de m’en parler. »
« Merci de ta confiance. »
« D’ailleurs, tu pourras m’en reparler
quand tu le souhaites,
quand tu en ressens le besoin. »
On peut poser des questions,
pas sur les détails sordides,
pas les questions culpabilisantes
que j’ai évoquées tout à l’heure,
mais on peut interroger la victime
sur ses ressentis, sur ses besoins.
Savoir comment ça se passe pour elle,
s’intéresser à elle.
Une victime de viol se sent
toujours coupable.
Il faut lui dire :
« Ce n’est pas de ta faute. »
En résumé,
empathie, encouragement, intérêt
pour la personne et déculpabilisation.
Alors, vous vous dites peut-être de moi :
« Bah, ça a l’air d’aller quand même,
elle parle tranquillement
devant 300 personnes.
Elle sourit. »
Les conséquences traumatiques du viol
ne sont pas marquées sur le front,
mais la souffrance est là.
Je fais encore des cauchemars,
des crises d’angoisse.
J'ai mal partout.
Je vais toujours voir le psy.
Quinze ans après.
Mais bien sûr que je suis privilégiée.
Parce que j’ai eu la chance d’avoir
des ressources personnelles, amicales,
sociales, financières
qui m’ont permis de tenir bon.
De me soigner, de ne pas m’effondrer.
Je parle aujourd’hui
pour toutes les victimes
qui n’ont pas eu cette chance.
Celles qui n'ont rien dit.
Celles qui ont essayé de dire,
celles qui ont dit et qu’on n’a pas crues.
Celles qui souffrent en silence.
Parler du viol avec vous ce soir,
ce n’est pas un règlement de comptes,
ce n’est pas personnel,
ce n’est pas intime,
ce n’est pas thérapeutique.
C’est politique.
Ça nous concerne tous et toutes.
Et c’est en changeant
nos regards, nos comportements
qu’on fera évoluer
la société tout entière.
Les victimes de viol ne méritent pas
le silence qu’on leur impose.
Aidons-les
et commençons par les écouter.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)